bonjour et merci d'être avec nous un sur
rt france le premier ministre l'a répété
tout à l'heure cette nouvelle loi anti
terroriste n'est pas une loi de
circonstance bonjour ce qui vous avez
raison le rouge avec deux observations
déjà la durée de la conférence de presse
a été vite emballé cette histoire et
puis autre chose intéressante
on a eu une majorité de questions sur la
crise sanitaire parce que c'est vraiment
cette projet de loi vous l'avez dit de
pérennisation elle est extrêmement
important donc je suis un peu surpris
moi de ce format et là je parle du
format du fond et on va parler du fond
mail entendu donc vous l'avez dit
sofiane énième projet de l'oral de
pérennisation et qui renforce déjà à ces
mesures qui était déjà appliqué pour le
renseignement et l'antiterrorisme bien
sûr avec plusieurs dispositions de la
loi de renseignement de juillet 2015 et
de la loi sur la sécurité intérieure et
gagnent quant au terrorisme on l'a
appelée la loi si le teint d'octobre
2010 est alors il faut dire quand même
que chaque 18 mois on a une loi en
français contre le terrorisme et je vous
rappelle que c'est plus de 20 lois en 30
ans et les actes actes délinquants du
terroriste continue à perdurer sur notre
territoire à dernier en date
rambouillet cette fonctionnaire de
police et très sincèrement aujourd'hui
ça ne lit pas pour la confiance des
français
hmm hmm gré même si on pérennise
beaucoup avec ce gouvernement charest
sophie et puis en fait aussi on l'a dit
à jean castex ladite 36 projets
d'attentats terroristes ont été déjoués
c'est d'ailleurs ces derniers mois c'est
la raison n'est plus tôt et alors bombe
à cette nouvelle voie dédiée en théorie
ça me permet de pérenniser des mesures
qui rêvait lit et qui finalement qu il
relevé les justiciers de l'état
d'urgence notamment sur les
perquisitions administrative on
rappellera que ça ne passe pas par le
juge
voilà un peu pour pour ce début
d'analysé suite à cette conférence de
presse à chaud vous voilà donc de ce
texte pour lutter contre le terrorisme
ce nouveau texte on entend beaucoup
parler du recours aux algorithmes pour
traquer la radicalisation sur internet
c'est surtout ça la grande nouveauté
cette fois si oui alors là c'est
extrêmement important parce qu'il ya un
vrai un vrai double enjeu cette question
là et c'est pour ça que je m'étonnais
qui ait pas eu de questions sur ce sujet
là parce qu'il ya déjà deux aspects il
ya le travail de terrain des services de
renseignement autant la dgs team pour
reconnaître anticipées dans les passages
à l'acte
et puis vous l'avais dit à la
surveillance numérique qui semble obsédé
vernement et là c'est beaucoup plus
opaque d'ailleurs j'ai lu ce matin en
préparant ce passage qui avait dans la
marne de majorité qui n'étaient pas
forcément très content de ça c'est le
volet renseignements et ça c'est pas
réviser sa pérennisation milk
controversé l'algorithme la mécanisation
finalement du traitement des données est
une nouvelle fois qu'elle vienne le
périmètre de cette loi ça on n'en sait
rien du tout et moi je pose la question
le quid des applis cryptée vous savez
télégramme signal est ce que ça aussi ça
va être pris en compte parce qu'elles
sont cryptés de nature donc
effectivement on ne peut pas se passer
en france d'un service de renseignement
adapté pertinents parce que
l'autorisation des données c'est
compliqué et puis après et puis après
c'est une question de fond dans cette
histoire c'est la surveillance massive
donc on joue finalement sur un lien ténu
entre la liberté fondamentale défense
des libertés publiques et la traque des
terroristes qui est extrêmement
importante
là dessus cette question là très
sincèrement j'aurais aimé que les
questions soient beaucoup plus
pertinente à ce sujet parce que c'est un
vrai vrai vrai problème de fond de
libertés publiques
vous savez on en parle beaucoup c'est la
balance du bénéfice et du risque juste
pour marraine la liberté des français
pour commencer à traquer les terroristes
et ce avant je suis assez inquiet je
voulais me le dire et surtout surtout
depuis la loi de sécurité globale on a
beaucoup beaucoup parlé sur l'antenne de
rtl france alors entre thématiques
abordées ce matin en conseil des
ministres la situation épidémique avec
l'adoption du projet de loi de sortie de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire jean castex
s'est exprimé à ce sujet tout à l'heure
pour sortir de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire le premier ministre évoque un
régime transitoire permettant le cas
échéant de reprendre des mesures pour
freiner l'épidémie qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire nicolas ben rien de bon
aujourd'hui on est à un point bas en
mars 2020 on est on est à un point b
maintenant des revenus moyens ou pas
c'est compliqué parce que des
gouvernement il faut rappeler volume
annuel m'apprend en décembre dernier il
avait dit si on arrive à 5000
contamination on va commencer à des
stériles et sio moi j'appelle ça une
camisole sanitaire est aujourd'hui
médias le maquereau il est obligé
d'ouvrir finalement le pays parce que
les gens ils ne peuvent plus être émises
aux sanitaires
mais qu'est ce qui va se passer donc là
une nouvelle fois bas la balance
bénéfice risque
et puis une tension populaire il ya une
tension sociale ya une tension
économique énorme
emmanuel macron ils sont pris entre deux
feux
aim croit feu donc c'est très compliqué
aujourd'hui d'arbitré là-dessus emmanuel
macron je crois de source sûre qu'il
parlera vendredi sport pour faire ce
programme de déconfinement janvier j'ai
sincèrement emmanuel macron s'exprimera
bien vendredi sur la situation sanitaire
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de ces
annonces de cette énième allocution du
chef de l'état j'ai déjà vous l'avez dit
vous avez le niveau magique ehiem
allocution du chef de l'état rappelez
vous ces deuxièmes troisièmes
compliments faits le 6 milliers de
confinement on a déjà eu plusieurs
allocutions du chef de l'état on verra
bien vous savez le couvre-feu il ya le
kilométrage et les attestations y avait
su lui si la question du pass sanitaires
d'ailleurs j'ai noté kim jong aztèque
notre cher que ministre lorsqu'il a été
question du vaccin a dit c'est pas mon
ne sait pas pour le moment encore où on
n'est pas des gels a donc finalement on
laisse entendre aussi que ce passeport
sanitaire ton départ by trees l'appareil
des grands événements culturels
d'appareils des grands événements
sportifs et le gouvernement cette
stratégie simple très simple compliqué à
l'appoint de combat libérer les français
mais aussi la vaccination dont il ya des
gros sujets sur la machination le gros
en ce moment a notamment sur les deux et
sur les gens qui vont pas forcément se
faire vacciner en ce moment même si on
entend toujours une petite reprise un
petit mieux une courbe qui monte
voilà mais c'est très compliqué emmanuel
macron il c'est pour moi il s'est
vraiment avancer ensemble qu'elle se met
d'ailleurs vous voyez très bien que
maintenant on commence un peu à
repousser on va territorialisées donc on
avance en tablant marche sur des oeufs
et je suis pas sûr qu'on doive attendre
beaucoup beaucoup de choses
concrètement pour revenir à une vie
normale et je crois et je crois
malheureusement que la camisole
sanitaire elle est encore un peu serré
pendant quelques semaines et j'espère
pas quelques mois je ne l'espère pas et
nous suivrons donc l'allocution du chef
de l'état vendredi merci beaucoup pour
votre regard nicolas vidal